bac mention
tu tentes lapointe ce mec ouais ouais
mais c'est super méchant ça tu es en
foutent quoi
tiens un truc entre que chan pas se
dégage quelque chose de malsain
dinars et en exclusivité sur ce plateau
carcérale avec carcérale c'est 13 10 le
platine et 13 condamnations
quelque chose réalisateur thermique je
suis un réalisateur tolère
il vient d'y avoir en direct sur votre
télé un attentat envers l'intégrisme en
pardon intégré sait comment ça s'appelle
ce qui vient de se passer un moment
j'avais mis la télé pour regarder ma
série sur la ligne 1 les méchants la
deuxième est méchant ah merde
et des vidéos de nous partout à la télé
sur internet et disco et les méchants et
qu'on va faire sauter la planète [ __ ]
art
les deux individus sont avec toi sont
recherchés au bâton
je matouba si vous êtes expert je suis
expert pour ce genre de voix font des
méchants barbus je suis déjà magar
négociations seraient vient du latin est
négociable et dans le monde du show
business je vous dézinguer la gueule ça
a très bien se passer
on a peur de la coller ça m'a dit ta
gueule avec ta tête de puces ou ce que
je peux vous poser une question qu'est
ce qu'ils ont acheté exactement un jus
antioxydants
antioxydantes non non mais comme ne
commençons pas à accuser les gens sur
des mauves sont mauvais jeu de mots
poursuivi par des
gens chez nous à la base on